welcome everyone so great to see so many
people logging on
we've got Greg here this is Andy we're
going to go
introductions right at 12 o'clock if you
are logging on and you can hear me
you'll note that I've muted you that's
just for the first portion of the
webinar and then I'll be opening up the
microphone as we progress through to the
Q&A so it's right up twelve o'clock I'm
going to go ahead and thank everyone for
being here yet again this is great Greg
and I are very pleased to begin what's
the first in a monthly series of
progressive webinars and seminars that
are connected to some of the courses
that he'll be teaching and making
available for open enrollment this first
session of course is on Aristotle on
virtue and vice and Greg is going to
take us through some excellent
discussion here some slides that he's
prepared for the occasion there will be
time again as I said before for QA but
please feel free to post a question or
comments at any time in the chat window
even though I've muted all microphones
and I will make sure that those get
addressed if they're technical issues
and that we read from those questions
during the Q&A in addition to opening up
the microphones for further conversation
so again Aristotle on virtue and vice
dealing with certain aspects of the Nick
McKeon ethics Gregg I'm going to go
ahead and ask you if you don't mind to
advance the slide so a little bit about
Gregg for those of you who may be new to
Reason IO or new to Gregg I am Andy
Shaka I'm Gregg's partner I'm also his
spouse so I'm a huge fan obviously but
reg is the president of reason IO he is
a specialist in putting philosophy into
practice and helping people understand
very complex ideas he is a well-known
contributor to scholarship on Aristotle
he's been teaching for nearly two
decades and he's been designing and
teaching courses on Aristotle Gregg is
an expert in applying Aristotelian
ethics in work he works with individual
clients organizations and institutions
and he is a popular online educator and
an advocate of virtue ethics I think
many people have actually come to know
about Greg through his YouTube videos
and his really strong
as a public philosopher so we're just
delighted that you're able to join us
today I'm going to sort of take it
backseat now and kind of run the machine
from behind the scenes and invite Gregg
to go ahead and take it from here again
if you have any questions any technical
difficulties just use that chat window
and I'll be sure to address them right
away but thanks everyone for being here
and Greg why don't you go ahead and get
us started
we'll start off by talking about what
we're going to do in the webinar I've
got a few opening questions for us to to
look at and get us thinking about why
why we're looking at Aristotle in
particular and how the topics that you
see the list here that we're going to
discuss fit in with some of our ordinary
you might say regular person notions of
moral ideas so we're going to discuss a
number of different topics here we're
going to go relatively shallow because
we're you know taking the time to cast a
rather wide net but we'll talk about
virtue and vice in our contemporary
culture and how that's different than
the Aristotelian tradition and we'll
talk about virtues and vices as key
criteria for making ethical decisions
for thinking about our moral development
and then we'll go into some of the real
meat key components to Aristotle's
conceptions of virtue and vice we'll
talk about this great idea that he has
of the virtuous mean we'll talk about
how he distinguished virtues by various
subject matters there's you know a
number of different virtues why are
there that many and then we'll talk
about how we become virtuous or vicious
I've reserved about 20 minutes for Q&A
and discussion so what I'm going to do
here in the first part is lecture and
then I'm sure there's going to be a lot
of questions or comments that will we'll
address after that so let's start with
considering these questions the first
one you know or first set rather what
specific people do you look up to and
what is it about them that you value
that's something that is worth
reflecting on from time to time that
what is it about them that you value
those are probably going to be virtues
another important question what actions
of a person are you willing to excuse so
long as they aren't typical of that
person but if that person keeps on doing
that sort of thing then here you said
that's enough those may be indicative of
what Aristotle calls vices think about
the all yourself and what traits that
you have that you consider morally good
and and that you not only possess but
also display in action and then think
about how often do you do that or how
consistently most of us myself included
what virtues that we have are not
entirely developed to the level that we
might want them and then think about
this when there aren't hard and fast
rules or clear outcomes to choose
between how do we in fact decide what is
right and wrong good or bad better or
worse do we just go by a sort of gut
instinct that can get us in trouble
quite a lot of the time virtue ethics
actually provides us with some some
useful answers to this so if you think
about those questions there are some
deeper implications buried within those
questions one of those is that we share
not entirely and and they're not always
entirely clear either but we have a core
set of moral concepts and often language
that goes along with it that correspond
to various experiences that we have and
some of those experiences may be very
positive some of them may be quite
negative
but these are things that aren't just a
matter of theory they have gripping
points you could say out there in the
world that we we live in another key
idea that you see running through those
sorts of questions is that we human
beings have some sort of enduring or
lasting character or personality
whatever you want to call something that
makes us who we are it's not the
entirety of our identity there's other
things that that fit into our identity
but it's at the core so if we talk about
a person being genuinely just you know
they seek out the right thing to do they
don't cheat people
as a matter of fact even the notion of
doing that is something they would find
repugnant if we want to say that that
person really is just then we would say
they have a you know an enduring
character that encompasses justice or
likewise when we talk about negative
character traits as well and this leads
to the third point you know we pick out
specific traits or dispositions that
that people have and some of these are
quite positive some of these are quite
negative one of the things I think is
very refreshing about virtue ethics as a
matter of fact I've had this experience
many times in the classroom telling
students that they actually have the
right or if they want to be granted
permission they have the permission to
say that some things are good and some
things are bad we can sometimes be
mistaken about what's good and bad and
we can be mistaken in applying those to
specific people and situations but that
doesn't mean that there isn't good and
bad and traits or dispositions that
people have likewise can be quite good
or quite bad the other thing that's I
think kind of core to this is that
there's a notion of bearing
responsibility not only for the actions
that we engage in or another thing I
should adhere to is the emotional
responses or motivations that we have
but also for the way that we are for our
being
when we talk about going back to the
character thing when we talk about
having a good character or a bad
character that's not just something that
shows itself in in one situation or
another situation it's something that
per ders through time and it's it's the
way the person is in in the world and in
relation to others and in relation to
their own self now we use these terms
virtue and vice in the present and I
want to get over a few hurdles at the
beginning that that might cause some
some misunderstandings or confusions so
virtue and vice have some really clear
systematically to
developed meanings in Aristotle's works
and I have not only in mind here the
nikah mccain ethics but also you know
the rhetoric or the politics when he
uses these terms they have some pretty
definite meanings and these meanings are
different from what I would say most
people using these terms mean or
understand by virtue and vice so I want
to distinguish for things that are
different from what Aristotle has in
mind just so there's no confusion about
this at the start and act you notice at
the bottom of this slide one of these is
a rather new term so if this was five
years ago I probably would only have
three terms here or three three things
here that I want to distinguish but now
we've recently added a new one so the
first thing is you know a lot of people
use the word virtue in a rather loose
weight just to mean what is socially
approved as moral or even as normal as
expected and then Vice would be the
opposite of that so they'll talk about
people displaying virtue and what they
really mean according to Aristotle would
not be that the person actually has
virtue but rather that they're acting in
accordance with with something that's
virtuous not everything that socially
approved is necessarily virtuous from
Aristotle's point of view it's possible
to have a very corrupt society or
culture in which some things that in
that culture are socially approved turn
out to be quite quite vicious and and
vice versa there can be virtues that are
unrecognized within certain societies so
it's not just about social approval the
second thing that I want to point out is
you know when we think about some some
rather restricted uses of virtue and
vice sometimes people will use the term
virtue often just applied to women in
terms of rigidity or chastity Aristotle
does not have that that sort of thing in
mind vice
on the other hand people think of
specific things that get called vices
like smoking or gambling or prostitution
and those could be those could be things
that fit into an Aristotelian vice for
instance if you if you smoke too much
and nowadays we know that really smoking
tobacco is bad for you so you probably
shouldn't smoke at all but let's say we
were back in the days when doctors were
still you know not prescribing
cigarettes but endorsing them and we
said well you shouldn't smoke four packs
a day you know if you do that would be
intemperate that would be the vice of
intemperance if it's rooted in your your
character as it probably is if you're
smoking four packs a day so it's not
that's not the sort of thing Aristotle
has in mind the other thing that you see
in a lot of contemporary references to
virtue ethics or teaching virtue
especially in k-12 schools are these
listings of generic good person terms
like grits or stick-to-itiveness or you
know whatever whatever you like courage
but there's no real analysis or
explanation of what these things mean
Aristotle would say that's not
particularly helpful you're just naming
something you're not providing an
understanding of it and then we have
this brand new term virtue signaling
which is is used to criticize other
people for acting or speaking or
oftentimes writing it gets used a lot in
terms of blog entries and social media
or a moding in a certain way in order to
convey being good or that others are bad
that's really it's a misnomer to call
that virtue signaling we should just
call it signaling that you're good
because it's possible to be good in ways
that aren't really connected to a
full-blown virtue but I do see why why
it's taken on the life that this term
has because it's very fun to accuse
people virtue signaling so let's talk
about Aristotle's meanings now
virtue the term that we're translating
is in Greek art a comes from the Greek
Agathon which means good and so moral
virtue is moral excellence is one way
it's sometimes translated or a
determinate form of goodness vice
there's two terms that we we often
translate as Vice one is Katia which is
just simply the opposite means badness
Moke theoria can also mean weakness but
it's used synonymously for for vice in
many of Aristotle's work so moral
badness or some sort of defect you know
something is lacking where it should be
or something is corrupted and if we go a
little bit further the virtues and vices
and this is probably one of the most
important points to stress these are
what in Greek are called hex ace the
singular for this is hexes we translate
this as habit but you don't want to
think about a habit of like biting your
nails or of drinking a cup of coffee in
the morning you want to think of
something that's a little bit more
substantive something that transfers
from situation to situation to situation
so biting your nails could be part of it
if biting your nails is how you deal
with anxiety and you feel too much
anxiety irrationally in situation to
situation a situation that might be a
vice in that case
Aristotle provides us with some general
conceptions of virtue and vice and we're
going to go into that fairly soon but he
also provides us with some specific
analyses of each of the virtues and
vices that he talks about and this is I
think where he's particularly helpful to
us because it's one thing to say you
know what these are in general it's
another to tell us well what is courage
and what is cowardice or to the other
extreme what is rashness it's not just a
term and it's not just being in the
middle position there's a lot of other
things rolled into that and if you read
nikka McCann epics
books two through four actually five -
if you want to see one it's just about
justice you will see a lot of very very
detailed discussion about how each of
these virtues and its associated vices
plays out you can also add to that you
know some of Aristotle's other works but
it's probably enough if you're first
starting out just to plow your way
through the nikah mccain ethics the
other thing that i want to highlight is
that his understanding of these virtues
and vices is placed within a systematic
although not entirely systematized
framework of a moral theory so there's
you know sometimes when you have
questions about it some of the questions
may the answers may be well you know if
you look at this other discussion here
in in the Nicomachean ethics or in
another work you'll see him clarifying
the point that you're asking about
unfortunately and this is a little bit
of a digression but i'm going to mention
this anyway aristotle is not as
systematic as you might prefer him to be
especially in this sense when he says
i'm going to talk all about X he does
usually talk quite a bit about whatever
that subject matter is but he'll also
make a couple remarks somewhere else in
his works that are relevant to that that
issue and so it's often useful to read
across the as we call it the
Aristotelian corpus that is the body of
his his texts now one of the the key
ideas that I said we're going to cover
in this is ethics with with virtue as a
sort of criterion or a standard so
Aristotle is one of the main early
representatives of what we call virtue
ethics his teacher Plato is another one
another rival school that comes on the
scene somewhat after Aristotle the
Stoics they are another example of
virtue ethics we see a lot of different
to ethics being developed within the
Western philosophical traditions all the
way going into the modern period same
things are happening also in other you
know sort of I don't even want to say
philosophical traditions let's call them
philosophical currents like massive
rivers if we think about Chinese
philosophy for example or Indian
philosophy so there this is a set of
traditions and approaches in moral
theory and virtue ethics went out of
fashion among academic philosophers
although not so much among ordinary
people who who tend to view things often
in this way but among academics it sort
of dropped out of the picture for quite
some time and there was a revival of it
in the in the 20th century and so virtue
ethics became formally distinguished
from several other main approaches in
ethics what some of the main ones would
be conch and deontology or various forms
of utilitarianism certain rights based
ethics that have their origins say in
John Locke or more recently in other
theorists virtue ethics would be
different from that and what's what's
really distinctive about virtue ethics
is that it looks at the the virtues as
being things that are intrinsically good
and vices as intrinsically bad so what
this means is that it's not just our
actions or our decisions that are good
and bad or the outcomes of them although
it's you know that's not to say that
those don't matter but our character
traits and our overall character as a
person matters as well and Aristotle has
no problem talking about a person being
in general a good person or in general
being a bad person or as having a a good
character trait on the one hand and a
bad character trait on the other hand
this is something that's really central
to virtue ethics and it doesn't see
those as
bad just because they lead to good or
bad outcomes or you know some other
criterion like that this is taken as a
sort of fundamental basis so there's
there's two kinds of corollaries that go
along with this one would be that
whatever helps you to develop virtue is
good and whatever leads you to develop
voice would be bad so you know when we
talk about somebody being a bad
influence on you they would not only be
bad in the sense that they're likely to
lead you into vicious behavior which
will then eventually lead to developing
a vicious disposition that that's
something that's sort of instrumentally
bad you know or we could talk about
culture as being good or bad in these
respects or institutions as being good
or bad in those respects as well another
really key thing to point out and I
think this is particularly helpful for
those of us who are tempted to start
applying virtues and vices as soon as we
learn about them is that many of us are
not actually virtuous or vicious with
respect to some of these virtues and
vices but Aristotle talks about so we
might not be cowardly but we might not
be courageous either in that case we
don't possess either the virtue of the
Vice but our actions and our responses
can be measured or or we can talk about
using it as a criterion here in
accordance with virtue or vice so if I
behave like a courageous person in
certain circumstances that doesn't make
me courageous but that does that do
something positive that means that I did
behave the way a courageous person would
behave at least part of the way likewise
if I if I act cowardly I'm not cowardice
is not yet rooted in my character but
it's a it's a bad action because of that
so what makes something virtue or or
vice Aristotle provides us with a
systematic conception of virtue and vice
some of the key points here that the
Virtue's really conduced to our our
flourishing or doing well the Greeks
have this term eudaimonia which is
difficult to translate and they realize
our human nature and our faculties the
vices as the opposites do the opposite
they stand in the way of our development
or even set it back they corrupt our
faculties and our nature there's there's
more to it than that Aristotle says that
virtues and vices have to do with
actions they have to do with emotional
responses and they also have to do with
types of goods and we're going to talk
about that when we get to the specifics
of them they also involve conscious and
motivated choice on the person's part so
they're not mere reflex actions when you
hear the word habit sometimes you know
people think it's just about practicing
something until it becomes unconscious
Aristotle says no no there's some
consciousness there's some knowledge
these are habitual dispositions to act
and choose and feel and desire and think
in particular ways
now the virtues here we're getting to
some of the the other things that we
want to talk about the virtues are mean
or middle states there between opposed
vices and what what tells you what that
is Aristotle says that it's right reason
or practical wisdom and rightly oriented
desire will inform the person and help
them to make that at that point now
let's talk about the virtuous mean and
the vicious extremes this is a really
key idea on Aristotle's part the
virtuous mean and when you see the word
mean that the Greek word there it means
also middle position
Maseo tastes it's situated between two
vicious extremes and so it's sort of
like Goldilocks and the three bears
right you have one extreme too much
excess you have another extreme defect
not enough so as opposed to say a
porridge that's too hot too cold just
right we can talk about our approach to
particular kinds of goods or emotions
as being just right so here's here's an
example you can see on the screen we've
got courage in the middle and courage
actually has to do with two different
emotions Aristotle says they're closely
linked to each other fear
Phobos and confidence Pharos in in Greek
and there's two ways to go wrong with
this cowardice
you know the person feels excessive fear
more fear than they should or fear at
the wrong sorts of objects and they lack
the confidence that would help them to
deal with that but notice on the other
side you've got this other vise and
there it's kind of got a defect in one
way
defective fear maybe feeling no fear
these are the people who run into danger
and don't even think about it along with
that usually goes excessive confidence
and both these are bad ways of being
Aristotle says he actually favors
rashness if you had to err on one side
courage is closer to rashness and to
cowardice but you you see that that what
we want is what's in the middle
likewise temperance the control over the
bodily appetites for physical pleasures
we have on one side the vice of
intemperance as we call it or you could
say lack of moderation and on the other
side we have a vice of insensibility
Aristotle thinks that you should have
some matter of desire right you should
in fact enjoy pleasures but you should
enjoy them for the right amount the
pleasure should not master you and force
you into doing all sorts of things that
are bad for you or bad for others if you
don't enjoy pleasures at all there's
there's actually something wrong
Aristotle thinks this is actually quite
rare but we could think of quite a few
people who are we might say a hedonic in
our own time now the mean is not just
the middle position there's also a
number of Rights or in Greek is the term
that uses de meaning what so the right
person you know for example when you get
angry Aristotle thinks you
you'd get angry in some cases but you
shouldn't get angry at the wrong person
right the right occasion or the right
the right you know a situation the right
motive what is what goods are you
driving at in acting or feeling this way
in the right time there's some times
when it's appropriate and some times
when it may not be appropriate doing the
action like the person who is virtuous
does the action is one criterion and it
sounds a bit circular but that may be
something we'll talk about in the Q&A
and the last thing I want to point out
is sometimes the mean is more opposed to
one of the vices I pointed out that that
courage is more opposed to cowardice
than it is to rashness the other thing
that I didn't put in here is that
Aristotle thinks that sometimes we have
to look at ourselves and figure out all
right which side do I need to lean
towards the most if I'm given to
indulging myself in pleasures of eating
maybe I need to be tougher with myself
and push myself past the mean and more
towards the the other side because I'll
bounce back hopefully into the middle
eventually now Aristotle distinguishes a
number of virtues by subject matters and
this is similar to what Plato if any of
you have read him does with the cardinal
virtues wisdom justice courage
temperance Plato also talks about piety
but Aristotle develops a much more
sophisticated approach that
differentiates other virtues that Plato
didn't talk about so virtue is concerned
with emotions and desires we already
talked about courage and temperance
Aristotle thinks that there is a virtue
of good temper or mildness as it's
called and then this is one of his two
next things are really major
contributions virtue is concerned with
how we deal with wealth or property and
honor so on the one hand we have
generosity which is on sort of a lower
scale and then magnificence which is a
public virtue when it comes to honor we
have the right amount of ambition
seeking out honor to the right extent
and then what he calls great-souled miss
or it's always difficult for me to
pronounce this magnanimity
megalo sukhiya is the greek for it
that's on a much larger scale and then
notice that he also has virtues
concerned with social life truthfulness
about oneself are you overly self
promoting well that would not be
truthfulness are you underplaying
yourself that would not be truthful as
either good humor Aristotle thought that
having a good sense of humor was
actually a virtue friendliness which has
to do with what you're willing to
participate in and what you're not
and then he devotes an entire book to
discussing the virtue of justice these
are the sorts of things that we want to
think about when it comes to these
specific virtues and vices what kind of
treatment does Aristotle give well if
you look at the nick mccain ethics
you'll you'll see that and why are these
helpful to us well it's partly because
of going into the details here's two of
the reasons why it can be so helpful he
distinguishes motives the why when it
comes to these virtues and these vices
it's not just winding up in the middle
place you want to be doing the right
thing for the right reason so he spells
that out and he also provides us a lot
of interesting and useful examples you
know for example when he's talking about
magnificence he talks about house
decorating you know when when you're
going to the shop and deciding how
you're going to outfit your your living
room that can fit into this this
particular virtue or vice the last thing
that we want to talk about is how people
become virtuous or vicious Aristotle
considers a number of interesting
possibilities maybe it's just luck you
know we hit the genetic lottery and
we're just naturally kind people it
could be that the gods or some sort of
you know other principle outside of our
control reaches in our head and changes
things around it could be teaching you
know like studying Aristotle for example
or it could be habituation and which one
does he hold out for its habituation
this involves rep
tician of action and also in some cases
emotional responses it's through doing
that we become a certain way he says it
also can include education so you know
reading the nikah mccain ethics can't
hurt but as he'll tell you in book ten
by itself that's not going to
automatically make you a virtuous person
interestingly aristotle considers music
to be part of this and if we think about
how closely music is tied in with our
own popular culture that might be an
interesting thing to follow up on it's
also good to have models that are
provided by other people to us sometimes
punishment colossus and greek is needed
to steer people onto the right track but
you can only get so far with punishment
the goal in all of this is developing
rightly directed desire and right reason
in the person and that's something that
has to happen over time it's not
something that you can snap your fingers
and it'll automatically be there like
say putting a chip into into a computer
so we have now reached the time for Q&A
i'm sure there's probably lots of
questions so we'll take them in turn
thanks Greg um what I'm going to do is
for everyone listening in I'm just going
to go ahead and unmute everybody and I
don't think it will get too crazy so if
you have a question go ahead and speak
back as you being on your in here see
sounds like someone that like someone
without headphones I have another really
bad feedback if I could just ask anyone
who does have headphones just to maybe
mute themselves and put their questions
in the chat window or turn down the
speaker there that seems to resolve it
but if there's anyone who has a question
go ahead and speak up and I will search
the emails to see if anyone emailed
anything new in it looks like Jim is
also typing something Jim I'll go ahead
and read that one you've got it written
but if anyone would like to start please
feel free now Greg I'll redo a question
that's just come in from Jim and it says
is it
possible to determine virtue and vice
apart from God so for Aristotle the
answer is definitely yes he doesn't
actually talk much in the logical terms
in his works in general there are a few
interesting references to the gods later
on in in the Nicomachean ethics but they
don't really get involved in this and
and in a way this is this is following
in the path of Socrates who's you know
talked to talked about as having brought
philosophy from the heavens down to
earth and focused on human affairs
Aristotle thinks that certainly the the
the aspect of rationality within us is
something that is semi divine it's it's
something that that is that elevates us
above above the animals but it's
something that also has to be developed
within us and and we don't need to make
any explicit theological discoveries or
revelations or references in order to
make sense of this now later on other
other continuations of Aristotelian
virtue ethics once you know Christianity
comes on the scene in in the West also
within the Islamic world of course we
have Jewish and Muslim and also some
some Christian writers they will take
Aristotle's framework and push it into a
larger theological framework that will
in some respects take Aristotle further
than then he intended to go a great
example that would be Thomas Aquinas but
even somebody like Thomas Aquinas thinks
that many of the things that Aristotle
is teaching can be understood by natural
human reason without any theological
commitments thanks great are there any
other questions that we wanted to go
over I see a few other people are still
on the line here
please feel free to just jump in with
any questions you might have while
you're thinking maybe formulating your
thought Greg we did get one question in
by way of email and I know you have
resources that you're going to provide
and we'll talk a little bit more too
about what the seminar entails but there
was a question about where someone ought
to start with Aristotle and
understanding this topic I know that
we're referring to the nikah median
ethics so do you want to just give a
quick explanation of kind of how that
fits into the other writings of
Aristotle for someone who's brand-new to
this and really you know wants to just
kind of jump in in a measured way yeah I
think really the nikah McCann ethics is
the place to start when it comes to
Aristotle's works as a whole there there
isn't any easy text to begin with they
all have they're they're all either
somewhat difficult or or very difficult
and we we often start people off at the
categories which is a short work but but
tends to confuse students I know when I
was an undergraduate it really confused
me until I finally figured out what was
going on in it and it's not if you
really want to study ethics I think
there's no point in not jumping right
into the nikah mckay in ethics I will
say this there is another major work by
Aristotle called the you Demian ethics
which covers much of the same ground as
a matter of fact three of its books are
identical to tria the books in the Nick
and the kinetics but it also provides
you some nice supplementary points of
view on things scholars are divided
about where exactly in Aristotle's
history which book came first in which
book came second so I don't really worry
too much about that the other thing I
will say too is like if you go on from
the nikah mccain ethics you would
probably want to also read his politics
and the art of rhetoric because those
cover a lot of the same issues and
give you again supplementary viewpoints
on things great so I think we've got
time for maybe one more question maybe
two it looks like we have a question
here from Johanna who asks my genetic
mildness be an issue with courage so I'm
imagining by genetic mildness I mean
something like a tendency to well looks
considered in two different ways one one
could be a tendency to avoid conflict
right and some people are naturally more
prone to to avoid conflict than than
others and then you might also mean
something like just you know being
naturally nice to people
mildness is sometimes characterized in
that way and I would say that so so
Aristotle actually does talk about our
temperaments and what he calls natural
virtues which are not there's something
that were were that are we're born
within the sense that we have a certain
temperament like some people are more
irritable than others and you can tell
that already when they're a baby but
most of what's going on
is a matter of how we shape ourselves so
if I'm already all use it myself as an
example on one of the reasons I do so
much research on anger is because I grew
up as an angry person and wanted to find
ways to deal with it I found Aristotle
was extremely helpful for that and I
could say well I'm naturally angry and
so I can't be you know I can't be
virtuous with respect to anger err so
let's say no no you can it's going to be
harder for you than it is for somebody
who's naturally prone to overlook things
and to you know the be nice and in those
certain ways but it's still possible you
would have to do more work and pay
closer attention to your your almost
instinctive reactions to get them under
control and so with with with courage if
you if you're naturally timorous
by the way in which you're born or
something like that or we can think
about what your culture is done to you
you know it's still possible to reshape
the person so okay yeah it looks like
we've got a follow-up question from both
Jim and Johanna and we may have to end
there but that what why don't I take the
followed from Johanna and then come back
to Jim's okay so her question then was
she said thank you so habituation is
going to be easier or harder depending
on genetics yeah although I think that
that genetics genetics doesn't do quite
so much as we we often credit it with
and this is actually a good launching
point you know we we often talk about
nature versus nurture and what gets left
out of that because it's not so easily
measurable and it doesn't fit into the
scientific paradigm as well is our own
capacity to rework ourselves in in
conscious ways to make choices and
sometimes to make dumb choices that
screw us up worse right so it's not
always about about you know steering
ourselves towards good and all three of
those you might say in the Aristotelian
perspective they all intersect with each
other so like I pointed out some people
yeah are going to have natural
propensities leading them towards a
virtue or towards a vice Aristotle
thinks that doesn't get you very far
he says that the natural virtues you
really can't count on them much you can
count on somebody who has become
habituated more than you can count on
somebody who just has a gut instinct or
anything like that but culture also
plays a major role because culture
influences the ways in which we're
habituated if you think about our own
culture that we inhabit right now where
we've got all these screens in front of
us that are bombarding us with with
ideas and in
information much of which is there to
try to arouse our desires that makes it
really tough I think in some cases to
develop certain virtues and we have to
sometimes we have to you might say take
control of the process there's not much
we can do with our genetics right we
were born bodies we've got but we can
choose what we're going to do with the
cards that we've been dealt but we do
have quite a bit more control over the
culture that we surround ourselves with
or that we allow into our homes and our
relationships and our heads straight I
think what we're going to do Greg sense
is almost 12:45 we've got another
question here from Jim and we'll
definitely get to that but just before
we went out of time
would you be able to just tell anyone
who's listening either now or to the
recording a little bit later what they
can expect in the seminar this Saturday
if they're still debating whether or not
they'd like to enroll in that I know
we're going to do a deeper dive into
some topics we explored today but if you
just summarize that and we'll come back
to the questions for anyone who wants to
hang around and continue the discussion
that would be great yeah so we're going
to spend two hours the last part of
which will be a Q&A session as well on
some of these topics going much deeper
into them so we'll talk about specific
virtues and and you know how this virtue
is situated in relation to this vice or
we'll talk more also about what it means
for you know rightly oriented desires or
right reason we'll talk more I think
about the role of choice involved in it
so that goes to some of these questions
about habituation and also be providing
some some additional resources as well
and we'll break it up so that you know
I'll go over a set of topics and then
we'll have you know maybe five to ten
minutes for question answer just on that
and then jump into another set and then
you know on and on like that great and
just for anyone who has questions about
the platform we'll be using this same
platform free conference call and so
you'll be able to log in to view and
call in or log in and use
computer speakers whatever is best for
you will likely start off at the same
sort of format where we have everyone
muted to start and then what we'll do is
just kind of take QA from there so great
we have another question it looks like
from Jim I'm just going to mute we've
got a little bit of background noise
here so I'm just going to need a few
people and then if anyone else is on the
line and you'd like to ask a question
just feel free to go ahead and put a
note into the chat and I'll be sure to
either open up your microphone and read
your question for you but Jenna
follow-up question is this what are your
thoughts on what part evolution might
play in the development of ethics well
that's a huge question I'm going to give
a really quick
Aristotle answer Aristotle himself
didn't take evolution into account but I
don't think that it's incompatible with
Aristotle's view on things you know for
example Aristotle thinks that we are
what we call social animals that that is
that it's very rare that a person truly
is isolated from some sort of community
that doesn't mean that they get along
with everybody those case would be they
don't but we we have developed to be
creatures that that interact with each
other and that has brought about a lot
of challenges that that ethics you know
has to respond to I think that by the
time that we get to theorists like
Aristotle I mean he could say that you
know evolution reveals to a certain
aspects of our nature but then he's not
all about you know sort of just
following our nature we're effectively
reshaping our nature so that we realize
it more fully and that I think that's
probably about as far as we could go in
terms of talking about evolution because
again Aristotle doesn't connect up with
that too much okay any other questions
or comments that anyone would like to
make we've got just a minute everyone a
little over time but kind of hard to
stop talking about it when we're also
engaged so this is really great Greg
obviously this is an excellent you know
sort of departure point for us just a
reminder for everyone
the to our online seminars will be held
this Saturday one at 10 a.m. Central and
one at 4:00 p.m. Central there's going
to be a follow up online course Greg
will sort of close us out by telling us
a little bit more about that and about
the resources that he has for us
including the playlist on YouTube in the
general comment space I just put a
little note with my email Andy Andy I at
reason io comm if you have any questions
comments or follow-up requests you can
always email me I look forward to seeing
some of you who have already signed up
for the seminar in the seminar on
Saturday and if you have any technical
questions prior to Saturday please feel
free to email those as well I know there
was a question about iPad versus phone
use free conference call is excellent I
think in Chrome but I know that some
devices treat the interface a little bit
differently so I would always recommend
logging on from a web browser and Greg
will be sharing both visual content and
a slide deck very similar to what you
see today so you will want to have the
opportunity to see not just here but any
problems with that I'm sure we can solve
them and you can email me again and EA
and di at reason io calm and Greg why
don't you just close this out with a few
final notes thanks again to everyone for
being here and we hope to see you on
Saturday sure so as Andy mentioned we
have the the seminars coming up but I
also have been developing some much
larger online courses and I split it
into two different courses and Parks I
don't want students to be totally
overwhelmed with how much material is
there these are in our reason I owe
Academy so I doing Aristotle's NIC and
mikay and ethics books one through five
and then six through ten and with each
of these there's a number of lecture
videos handouts lesson pages
usually a quiz for each of the books
discussion forums it's you know sort of
regular online courses and so if you
like the kind of stuff that I do here
you may want to check that out the other
thing is I do have an Aristotle playlist
in my main YouTube channel some of you
may have come across it already I was
just checking on it today it's got over
a hundred videos in it it's been been
adding quite a bit to it
it's kind of always funny to see just
how much stuff there is in those and I'm
still continually adding more videos
because I'm doing core concept videos on
Aristotle's categories so if you're
having trouble with that tax deal you'll
want to check those out as Andy
mentioned if there's any issues go ahead
and email her you see her email here
she's just a whiz at all of these sorts
of technical things that are that are
way beyond me we're ended up being a
great team together and I'm really happy
to have put this on so thanks to
everybody for attending and for your
questions I really enjoyed this and
we'll be doing many more of these in the
months to come thanks Greg have a great
day everybody and we look forward to
seeing you in the seminar space or email
me thanks so much bye-bye